[Music]  every step you take you're moving  forward a moment in time  what if for every step you take  backwards it moves backwards in time  [Music]  I'm 11.  a number that looks like two people  standing next to each other this is our  last weekend before Middle School I want  to go backwards not forward  one is the person you used to be and the  other one  is the person you're becoming who wants  to go back like two months then we come  somewhere all over again  and the older I am  the more complicated my life gets  [Music]  he's dead  the makeup hat  try and find out who he was  but this is on us  [Music]  I have not looked for someone who's gone  companies waiting for this guy to come  home  [Music]  those are some tough years  it can be so hard to know what's right  you'll make it through  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]